I was a hell of a good artist a world
war two illustrator and now I can barely
write my name
[Music]
I heard what happened to you five of
them jumped him to miracle he survived
[Music]
you taking your meds
I got beaten with an inch of my life for
no reason
one foot in front of the other you got
it mark embrace the pain but I've
created a world where I can heal what is
all of this
welcome to Marwan it's my art
installation you're an artist that's a
complicated story what huh me do you
really want to know yes they kicked
every memory I ever had out of my head
[Music]
everything from before the attacks come
so my dolls have to tell a story these
are the women of Marwan and they protect
mark we're one on the same pal from the
bad guys
let's go
I thought I heard you yelling for more
gumbo not gumbo no gumbo all of the
dolphin Marwin people you know
yeah there's Anna yeah Julie hell yeah
Karl Allah you can't keep on running
away from your problems Roberta are you
gonna go to the sentencing you need to
face those jerks who beat you up no
really sure how to do this
her pain is our rocket fuel the life I
once had was taken away from me but I'm
still here I have hope and I have my
town
and I have my friends back don't be okay
anything is possible in Marwan bottoms
up girl
people need to see how special Marwin
really is to life to love to the women
of Marwan
[Music]
you
[Music]